a gunman is canonized while his victim
remains paralyzed I speak of former La
gang member aren't they all Jared Nava
who went from facing life in prison to a
job at the California state capital
thanks to Governor Gavin
Nome I know I haven't seen a worse hire
since this
[Music]
guy he was too unpopular to be in a
gang it's all detailed in a an LA Times
profile on Nava which softens his
violent past by chalking it up to a
rough childhood incites Nim to make the
case that he's re rehabilitated in 2012
get this Nava shot into a car carrying
the relatives of rival gang members and
one of the victims was a 16-year-old
girl who was hit in the back and
paralyzed from the waist down Nava was
convicted on four counts of attempted
murder and he was sentenced to 162 years
in prison or what prisoners call Ving a
full
Biden 162 years he's going to have to
eat a lot of balance in nature to ever
see Freedom
again but get this he served only eight
years after Nome commuted his sentence
in 2020 which was not what California
wanted when they asked for help with
commuting I know I felt bad putting that
in there but 8 years of 162-year
sentence and here we thought prison
reform only affect nonviolent prisoners
but come on it's California to serve all
162 years of his sentence he would have
had to done something serious like it
caught using a plastic straw while
misgendering a
carjacker get this after a filmmaker
introduced Nava to the Secretary of
State Senate Nava gets a job in the
Department of Public
Safety I know so you heard that
correctly a dude who paralyzed the
16-year-old girl now works in public
safety so what's next putting in
arsonist in charge of preventing
wildfires placing a repeat shop
shoplifter in charge of preventing
retail theft and what exactly is going
to be his role in public safety teaching
gangs to use their turn signals on their
next
driveby they say he'll focus on prison
reform which today in California means
no prison at
all ominous ending Michelle so you're
telling me Michelle there's no one more
qualified than this guy like hey we ran
out of qualified applicants get the guy
who paralyzed the girl it's uh this is
so disgusting and you know this puff
piece they did in the la la times was
all about was rough and tumble
upbringing it was awful and so of
naturally he just joined a game because
that's what you do when you have an
awful upbring right Tyrus I mean you
know yeah that's what you do yeah the
requirements I was too
tall but I will say that you know I I
there are plenty of stories that go the
absolute opposite opposite direction
where people grow up in awful
circumstances and find their way out to
something good I there are plenty of
them what makes me the most nauseous
about this story is Gavin Nome saying
after I met him and I saw now that he's
made something of his life I went back
to my office and I cried I wept it's
like but Gavin did you happen to go meet
the young 16-year-old girl M what about
her future what about her life are you
crying over that that's my simple
question for you Governor mhm well you
know what
he Shameless plug for Fox News will be
on Fox cat on Thursday debating Ron
DeSantis perhaps we should ask him
then by the way I'm all for Second
Chances but this seems like a weird
Second Chance yeah when I lived in
California I had to work at Boston
Market yeah you didn't even you weren't
even qualified I never shot
anybody not even like an adult like I
never shot an adult no let alone a child
and then I you know I only able to find
restaurant employment mostly and I look
again I don't think anybody really likes
this I think there's a lot of people who
might pretend that they like this
because they feel like that's what
they're supposed to do but I think most
people might say he you know I kind of
have someone in my family who's been
looking for a job for a while or when I
said Criminal Justice Reform I didn't
mean for people who shot and
paralyzed nobody really likes this I
think a lot of people feel like they
need to pretend like they do yeah yeah
you know what imagine being the one of
the finalists for that
job oh I'm sorry you didn't get the job
who got it this guy who paralyzed a girl
everything about this is the is what's
wrong with our Administration it's this
is the equity this is the Reverse Racism
it's not his fault that he he attempted
to kill four people yes he even told
them it was time to die even in court
when they when the I think it was the
judge said to him and he said he's like
charging him with four counts of
attempted M he like what are you talking
about that's just life so he was
unremorseful and he didn't care he had
40 years that he had to actually serve
which is 10 for each life that he
changed now he didn't get hit with a
bullet but that's not something you just
forget about now then he get then they
decide they pick him they take him out
they give him a job and then they cry
about it's virtue signal it's worse he's
a minority he's from a rough
neighborhood that's not an EXC for
nothing like everything and everyone in
here half this audience had a rough
upbringing I guar Dam toe you they had
choices they make they decided whether
they get in a car to go rob a store or
not they made the choice not to no
consequences because it's not your fault
you're a minority we have to help you
look what I've done I've taken one of
them and I even gave him a job you
didn't apply for that job he even he
still if you caught him on the sign like
what do you do like I don't
know and you gave him these things yeah
and you just
hope that he doesn't betray you right
because what that happens is then
someone else be like I'm going to do
that I'm going to release all the
17-year-olds that attempted murder and
rape and give them a second chance and
when statistically 80% of them recommit
it's the system we tried they just can't
learn it's just not that's why we have
to take reading and math out of schools
because the blacks and the Browns they
you know they we got to help them and
that's that mentality and this this dude
should have done 40 years or you know
what his job should have been changing
her colomy bag yeah Wheeling her up the
steps how about that how about some
community
service you know Joe the good news now
that he's a citizen he won't be able to
legally buy a gun right well this tells
me we got to do something about the
prison to Sacramento
pipeline I don't know how many years did
you serve eight years yeah so he had
time to his LinkedIn profile must have
been tight to lock down that job to go
from 162 years to 8 years there's got to
be something in between there's nobody
who gets something that wrong where you
can go in you know if if you go into the
deli and say give me a half pound of
turkey and they give you 162 pounds of
it somebody gets fired they don't get a
government job but the points everyone's
made are excellent about Gavin Newsome
this is just him showing what what a
narcissist he thinks is that he can be
so Godlike that he can come and bestow
his grace upon people now did he he
didn't say anything about crying over
the victim no cried over the although it
could have been maybe he was getting a
hot oil treatment a little bit of B5
dripped into his eyes but it it just
goes to show that this this is not
working that someone could commit a
violent crime like this and and then the
sentences mean nothing yeah but
something that really struck me about
this and we see in so many of these
stories is that he talks about his
upbringing it's tragic that he went this
way but what you see in all these
stories is no father in the house and
that's what the policies that people
like Gavin Newsome put forward they take
the fathers out of the house and that's
why this keeps repeating all right there
you go all
right a politician turns the tables on
reporters who told fables hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else